amazon wants mgm to push forward with
one big reboot other than stargate and
bond but what will it be
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so the main reason why amazon bought mgm
is because of the massive back catalog
and the intellectual properties mgm owns
it's one of the oldest and largest of
all of the big major studios and it has
a massive reservoir of movies and tv
series that amazon want to take
advantage of and if you are a regular
sidetracker you'll know that amazon want
mgm to push forward with three big
projects one is going to be bond
one will be stargate and one will be a
big reboot or a sequel from something
that mgm already owns a big reboot of
one of their older projects and after
talking to some people that work in and
around mgm i've been able to get a list
of what projects they're looking at and
one project that they would absolutely
love to do
but that there might be a big problem
with so first what's on the list
space balls may the sports be with you
is genuinely something that they are
looking at at making a sequel
amazon
with a cheeky little sense of humor
would like the opportunity to poke fun
at disney star wars right now is as
popular as ever was disney making so
much star wars product that actually
there's a lot to kind of make fun of
and it would just be a very simple fun
and easy score for mgm because let's be
honest spaceballs is still a very loved
movie
my favorite being john candy i'm a mog
i'm half man half dog i'm my own best
friend
it's just a wonderful movie and
ludicrous speed should be engaged
immediately and it'd be a shame that mel
brooks won't be involved but i'm certain
there are other people that could
somebody like seth macfarlane i think
could do
an amazing job with this if they could
get him on board um but there are plenty
of people out there that could do a
really great job with this baseball
franchise it should also be said that
space balls from 1987 was actually 84
from the top 100 list of mgm's most
successful movies so this really is
pretty high up on there on the list of
from all of the intellectual properties
amazon now own
a surprise hit at the time of movie that
spawned several sequels was 1995's
species
now again this is another sci-fi movie
and i'm gonna have to tell you
all of the list of films that i was been
told mgm are looking at are at least
loosely sci-fi movies
species was a film by a very beautiful
alien that came down to earth and we all
ended up running around hunting it it
was a very cool movie unfortunately did
spawn two or three sequels that weren't
so good it did actually land itself in
the 31st spot for the out of the top 100
most successful mgm movies of all time
so again pretty high up on the list here
but also amazon are going to look at the
success of films like suicide squad that
the success really came a lot from the
popularity of the harley quinn character
a very sexy character in a movie can go
a long way to increasing his popularity
species would give them an opportunity
to cast somebody incredibly beautiful in
a role that they can unfortunately
exploit for its sexuality 1983's war
games came in at 48 in the top 100 of
the mgm's most successful movies it
could be a very politically relevant
movie right now and to be honest it's a
future that was imagined back then and
in terminator and so on that's actually
kind of becoming true today
most of our systems and most of our
defenses are controlled by central
computers we're also getting into a
world now where quantum computers and
actual artificial intelligence are
becoming not just science fiction but
science reality
if they do decide to remake this movie
they would have to up the ante but if
they do make this film they can make it
really relevant to today's world and
particularly if we consider the problems
going on in the ukraine and the rebirth
of the cold war
so
i actually think this is a film they
could remake but out of the list i think
it's the least likely the film that
seems to be however most popular would
be a complete reboot a hard reboot
whereas some of these other movies we
talked about could be sequels or soft
reboots 2001 a space odyssey seems to be
the movie that is most popular and most
likely to actually get made
this is a film that quite regularly
appears at the top of the most
successful and most popular sci-fi
movies of all time especially when you
consider how influential it was
so many movies have either copied or
been inspired by 2001 space odyssey ever
since it was actually 51st in the list
of the top 100 most successful mgm
movies of all time war games and species
actually ranked higher for how much
money it took
but from an actual point of view of
impact and longevity 2001 a space
odyssey is by far the most successful
movie in this list and probably the most
likely to get made my source mgm thinks
that if this other movie i'm about to
mention can't be made
then this is the one that will be but
the movie that they would love to remake
if only they could is 1956's forbidden
planet
now
this movie was a first in lots and lots
of ways for one it's got leslie nielsen
in it actually playing a serious part
the robbie the robot
character who we all know is iconic
sci-fi robot and was one of the first
robots to actually appear in a sci-fi
movie like this not the first but
one-off but he was definitely probably
the first to actually have like a
central part he wasn't just a tin can
with legs he was actually a character in
the movie he could also say that
actually he took up a massive chunk of
the budget as about a sixth of the
budget went on building the robbie the
robot so i mean that was a hell of an
investment considering the the overall
budget it was one of the first movies to
be entirely set either in space or on
another planet no part of the movie was
actually set on earth it was also one of
the first movies to ever show um humors
traveling faster than the speed of light
in a ship that they'd built
i should have said is it the first movie
of any genre to have solely electronic
music as its score mgm would desperately
love to make this movie and to return us
all to alt f4
but there is a massive problem
they don't actually own the rights to it
so first of all warner brothers bought
the rights but they never did anything
with it then they sold the rights to new
nine cinema now new line cinema were
going to actually create a reboot but it
never got off the ground
um strazinski from babylon 5 fame was
actually involved in trying to have a
reboot as well but again it was never
successful but scripts and everything
were written at the moment warner
brothers own the rights again so they
could potentially in cooperation with
mgm produce something so what do you
think about this short list
do you think it's interesting actually
that all of these projects are sci-fi
related please get in the comments and
let me know what you think also what
film out of these do you want to see the
most personally i want to see spaceballs
the most but that's because i'm a
complete child
get in the comments tell me what you
think though
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification thumbs up not thumbs down
thumbs down helps nobody
and also if you enjoy the content and
you want to support the channel please
consider becoming a fully fledged
sidetracker hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you soon
[Music]
you